The Joe Rogan Experience I was reading
something that there's a lot of women
who are taking some new there's some
like an injection that kills your
appetite and they're doing it what is it
called I actually know exactly what
you're talking about because someone
what is it called
it mimics how you had like the stomach
surgery
like in terms of appetite curbing right
I know this because yesterday someone
told me that someone they know got it
they were talking about the Kardashians
and they were talking about how they
lose all this weight like the larger
girl with a Chloe they were saying that
she's always had a problem with weight
now she's ripped and that this is what
these people are taking she's larger
you know the conspiracy on that one is
she's O.J Simpson's daughter yeah that's
a conspiracy I don't yeah I buy it I'd
like to get a strand of her hair and run
it through a lab I bet you can I bet
they'd sell it to you
how much I
what I don't know I probably should have
to brush up against her true you
probably couldn't get that close no
security attack for you I if there's
that fine line you know as a woman it's
like you don't want to win or whatever I
have an issue with that whole family's
ethos there were parts of them that I
thought were so good for the older parts
and and
I guess at the end of the day this goes
back to you know you can't have someone
be your end-all be-all like whatever
they do these they they seem sad and
they live in this bubble they probably
have a lot of yes people I think as a
consumer put on your [ __ ] hat and
realize like these people are not
they're selling you tummy tea detox tea
waste trainers these are people that are
deeply unhappy with their bodies as most
women are but they're they don't you
don't have access to the same things
they do so you can work out and diet all
you want you're never gonna look like
that and I think that's really hard for
people to wrap their mind around when
you look at Instagram and stuff it's
really there's that disconnect that
cognitive disconnect of like no one
looks like that but I sure would like to
try yeah and this is not a happy person
but this is also a person who's been
called the larger one and ugly and all
these things her whole life so that's
because this is larger psychologically
I'm not it's not your fault
psychologically damaging but she's this
shot works I can't believe people don't
know I can't believe people keep buying
into this I haven't taken it
is your appetite bothering you no it
wasn't that it's called I I believe this
is what it's called looking it up uh
semi-glutide is yeah the uh actual drug
but there's like well other names right
there how many times the Kardashians
tried to sell us I was trying to see if
this is what they were actually talking
about that is semi-glue tied is what I
read yeah yeah so uh no I think I I was
I asked them for like a weight loss
something because of the stuff I was
taking I was like I should be losing
weight and they're like oh take this
what are you eating buddy no I changed
myself a little bit you're not big
that's where I'm not a big boy that's
why I haven't taken it yet big boy is
that all right you say big boy you say
big boy you can't say big girl Big Boy's
a little yeah well it's less offensive
you can say big girls my favorite thing
about the Kardashians is in general this
is my take it's like human beings should
have personal sovereignty and someone
shouldn't influence you that much like
if that bothers you so much that they're
materialistic and that they get their
butts done like that's on you and I the
problem though is I'm saying this as a
55 year old wealthy man and I'm not
influenced by them but if I was a young
girl and I Look to them as being the
like that's one of the things that
really [ __ ] the people on social media
is that you're looking at other people
as these are examples of like what's
ideal and then if your body doesn't
match that right of your lifestyle
doesn't match that and then you have
this uh horrible theme feeling that
you're not valuable you're not worthy
and so the problem is that a lot of
people look to these very wealthy people
with all this plastic surgery is that
that is the highest level of achievement
because these are the most popular
people right the most social media and
the most money and it influences people
in a negative way I come I agree with
all of it I agree with all of it you
know
if you're younger that's not your fault
that you are looking at that if you are
older and we'll say like if you're in
your 30s you have seen this family in
particular but just in general you've
seen social media grow and you've seen
this family grow and you've seen all of
the snake oil over all this time so for
you to be surprised or let down at this
point is really more an indictment on
your intelligence yeah really like you
think the family that would sell their
own children for money you think the
family that sold you tummy tea and
diarrhea pills you think looking at a
diarrhea pills diarrhea you think this
is do they really have diarrhea pills I
think their detox tea gives you diarrhea
that's how you detox you you take a [ __ ]
I don't think that's the mechanism
involved in detoxification detox tea but
you would also not take deep that's why
it's not real but what is it tummy T's
they make you take a dump I literally
have never dump it out people say tummy
tea the the most thought I've given to
it is saying the those words just there
I've never thought about it at all
chances are it involves taking a [ __ ] do
you know what it is even the semi-glue
tied is going to make you have diarrhea
where do you think these times
you're not sweating out the fat like
someone putting in work and but tummy
tea is that real what the [ __ ] does that
do does this is earlier appetite this
was like early 2000s Instagram marketing
tummy tea
these are like detox teas and these
Family Hair gummies everything they put
their gummies to make your hair grow
they sell every collagen like hair it
probably actually does help the the
health of hair you can take biotin
biotin you know but like I take biotin
I'm never gonna have like lustrous pony
hair like it will grow in here I had a
baby so it's like you know what I look
like all the hairs in the front broke
you know how like Puerto Rican guys get
like the Caesar like it's a very like
Guido look that's what I have like a
full Caesar in the front because your
hair breaks and it will never it will
never look great uh no matter how much
biotin I take and so I think at a
certain age it's on you like if you're
still looking at these petulant women as
some sort of inspiration like that's on
you yeah
yeah I think so too but I think you're
right about young people the the thing
that's [ __ ] is that
that empty Pursuit Of Fame for no reason
like it used to be that if someone you
know if you want if you were younger and
you look to some celebrity that was a
singer Beyonce or whoever it was you're
like God I wish I was like her right
well that's someone who's like putting
out like
this incredible work of art that affects
millions of people they dance to it they
sing to it like it's very inspirational
and aspirational like God that would be
amazing to be like her she inspired me
to get into music she inspired me to
pursue my dreams but when the dreams are
just like making money and like sticking
your ass out and you know and just
taking these doctored pictures I I
I don't feel the need to defend this
family the one thing I will say
you know you have someone however this
came about made a sex tape with a guy
she was dating and that guy's obviously
a scumbag I can respect that she didn't
just lay down and I'm saying this is a
joke and take it like that tape leaked
or however they got a hold of it this
was going to be used against her this
guy had the tape and he's had other
tapes and to Pivot because there were
plenty of people who have leaked sex
tapes that have not risen Like a Phoenix
right yeah I can be okay with that and I
can be okay with and I will say this
and I feel like we talked about this on
the podcast but like if you are not rail
thin if you have thighs if you are you
know and this is for a lot of women of
color in particular but even if you're
just a white girl and you don't have
Nordic model boy hips these women sort
of champion dressing for your curves and
when you don't see a reflection I'm a
white upper middle class woman and I
still almost am like brought to tears
when I put on jeans because my thighs
are like a little big so they kind of
made it okay
and I can respect that but anything else
I'm just
I'm just appalled at them but I can
respect making it okay if you have
naturally the curvy body that they have
surgery to get if you have a body like
that I can respect creating a place
where as a girl you might feel okay
about the body that you have the [ __ ]
up thing about that whole skinny look
like really scrawny look that some women
think is attractive like men don't think
it's attractive but that's not thing
that's not something that guys like it's
actually it actually has less to do with
guys and more to do with
an inculcation of an ideal of
brainwashing that is hard to unscrub and
it has to do I mean it's deeply from
modeling photos because models models
they're like hangers the clothing hangs
and a lot of gay guys model and they
model women's bodies after boys bodies
right this is all about how the clothes
will hang and it's so built into our
society to be smaller which ties to
feminism and making yourself smaller but
I cannot even though I love my body like
I look at those women and I'm like
that's what you want and really skinny
I'll never have it it doesn't matter but
most women like it's just a brainwashing
thing and you can't get out of that it's
you can acknowledge that that's
unattainable but and I talk about this
in my stand-up forever ago like every
girl looks at her body or like I just
want to lose five pounds even if you
don't need to like it's a thing and it
has less to do with being attractive to
a man and just being acceptable
and most men good guys they don't think
about women I always try to explain to
women like
the thing that what you're putting your
body through and what you're putting
yourself through mentally with thinking
you're unacceptable most men aren't
looking at you like that you at your
worst your husband's probably still like
that looks really good right like if
your wife didn't shave her legs
perfectly Are You Gonna Leave the Room
no
and I think this has to do with
self-esteem and the way that we treat
that we educate women and the
disinformation about their bodies
vaginas thighs hips all that stuff that
good men don't actually care about all
that [ __ ]